this is a production of cornell
university
well thank you neil for the introduction
and basically today what i'm going to do
is i'm going to talk to you all about
the work that we've been doing at purdue
with led lighting
so this is our our greenhouse is at
purdue and as you can see our
our leds uh nice and glow in there
so in terms of a floor culture and you
know
we can talk about other crops we tend to
really focus on light
quantity light quality as well as light
duration
and with each of these we can manipulate
them to
have our crops do specific things so
with light quantity you know
we primarily use high pressure sodium or
metal halide lamps to
increase the daily light integral with
light quality we can use filters or
shading
and then with photoperiod primarily
growers would use incandescent
lamps obviously those are being phased
out of production so
ultimately these are the responses that
we're looking for well now
we have good sorry so now we have
leds which we can use to basically look
at both
well look at photosynthetic
photomorphogenic as well as
photoperiodic
light responses so one of the primary
areas of research for me
is lighting of young plants and that is
primarily because
when we think of northern uh latitudes
this is what we often see we see very
low light daily light integrals
and for propagators they really want to
minimize the amount of time
that those young plants are in the
greenhouse they want to optimize the
quality
and also just
you know reduce that timing when we
think of the photosynthetic daily light
integral
outdoors in the north we typically have
anywhere from 5 to 20 moles of light
and to produce a high quality young
plant
research has shown that we want to be
more within the 10 to 12
mole range so when we move within a
greenhouse we can have further
reductions of anywhere from 50
or more uh or less excuse me due to the
structures the glazing material et
cetera
where we can ultimately have a daily
light integral within a greenhouse
during pr
peak propagation of anywhere from one to
five moles which is
is quite low so this are basically two
maps
and we're looking at the average
greenhouse daily light integral in
february which is when we're propagating
a lot of cuttings and also growing a lot
of seedlings
and this is the average greenhouse daily
light integral
so you can see that in the north there's
a large benefit
in terms of using supplemental lighting
to get that target dli of 10 to 12 moles
of light
so we've been doing uh research with
rooting of cuttings for several years
this is work that we
looked at using high pressure sodium
lamps
and as you can see when you increase
that daily light integral you obviously
increase that
root dry mass you end up with more
branching so you
ultimately can get that cutting out of
the production house
much faster so when we look at northern
latitudes especially like say new york
michigan
daylight integrals in this range are not
uncommon during that time period
this is some work done at michigan state
and you can see that
here what they've done is they basically
have looked at when to use high pressure
sodium lighting whether it's
early on or later on in terms of the
plug production and you can see the
effects of
obviously providing supplemental light
during three stages of
of the seedling stage and
ultimately it reduces the time to
produce that plug but also increases the
quality
so when we look at biomass production
it's very uh cultivar dependent
so we see that root dry mass increases
with increasing daily light integral
obviously each species is responds
differently
we see that photosynthesis also
increases as we would expect
so this is what basically what we're
looking at is this is that
um stick and then we start to see that
um that daily like excuse me as daily
light integral increases
photosynthesis increases so this leads
me to
the first study that we're going to talk
about this is some work that
my former graduate student chris curry
worked on he basically wanted to look
at supplemental lighting
using various sources so what we did is
we basically
looked at leds where we had 100 percent
red light
or and no blue light and then we had
increasing amounts of blue light from
anywhere from 15 to 30 percent
we also had our control which was our
high pressure sodium lamp
and we provided 70 micro moles of of
light
for 16 hours each day
so here's our spectral quality for the
various leds
and of course the high pressure sodium
so you can see our
our different peaks
and this is basically what we found so
we have our high pressure sodium and our
increasing amount
of blue light from zero all the way up
to 30.
and what's the the one thing that you
notice between
both the impatiens and the petunia
in terms of uh above and below ground uh
biomass
yep exactly there there were there were
virtually no differences
so that was i guess you know it depends
on who you're talking with
whether that's good or bad so we also
looked at photosynthesis for the the
three species and basically we had
the same photosynthetic rates under high
pressure sodium lamps or under 100
red or with increasing amounts of blue
light
so what we did is then we grew the
plants under a common environment so we
took them out of propagation
and we placed them into a greenhouse
with 20 degrees celsius
and a target daily light integral of 10
to 12 moles of light
and we finished them to see if there
were any residual effects of
basically propagating them under high
pressure sodium lamps or leds
and again we did not see any difference
in time to flower
heightened flower nodes below the first
flower
so really some of the conclusions that
we were able to make from this study
is that there were very few statistical
differences among the cuttings
when we used various sources of
supplemental light
and obviously there were few differences
among flowering plant responses
so there were no beneficial or
detrimental effects of using
leds for vegetative propagation
so our next study we wanted to basically
look
at seedlings so we think of a cutting
and when we get a cutting you know it
obviously comes from either
central or south america or africa
and we that cutting spends about a week
in the greenhouse
forming callus and then it's in the
greenhouse anywhere from two to three
weeks more
when we have a seedling that seedling we
place it under lights
right after germination and it's in the
greenhouse anywhere from three to four
weeks
so we basically had uh similar
lights so 100 red um 85
red 15 blue and then the 70 and 30. we
had a different
uh or different leds that we use in this
study
and we increased our light intensity to
100 micromoles for 16 hours a day
again here's our spectral distribution
for the various leds as well as the high
pressure sodium lamps
and we used a wide variety of bedding
plants so these are basically the top 10
bedding plants that are produced in the
u.s
i'm just going to present to you today
the petunia just because of
of time but with the seedlings we
definitely saw dramatic
differences between those that were
produced under leds versus uh the high
pressure sodium lamps
so here what we're looking at is uh the
stem length
so with plugs we want them to be nice
and compact right because we're going to
one grower is going to produce them
place them in a box and ship them to
another grower so we want these
these plugs to be nice and compact so
you can see that under high pressure
sodium lamps
they were much more taller compared to
under leds
so when we inc when we used blue light
we tended to have even more compact
seedlings when we looked at stem caliper
there were basically no differences so
in terms of stem caliper we want
a sturdy ceiling that's going to be able
to withstand transportation
not break in that box
in terms of root dry mass obviously root
dry mass is important because
if those seedlings root faster they're
going to be rooted into that
plug tray so there were basically not
a whole lot of differences the only
difference were between the 85
85 percent red 15 blue and the
uh 70 30. again would shoot dry mass
not a lot of difference as well so again
we wanted to grow these plants out
in a common environment see if there
were any residual effects of the
supplemental lighting during propagation
and as you can see here they pretty much
all flowered
at very similar times so there were no
statistical differences as well as
the height at flower
so we found that plug quality was
similar whether
the seedlings were grown under high
pressure sodium lamps or under leds
or in some instances they were a better
quality
and the finished plant quality was not
significantly influenced
by the propagation supplemental lighting
so then this led to the next study where
there's been an interest by u.s growers
of producing plugs indoors so we wanted
to look at
whether we could produce a high quality
bedding plant seedling indoors using
sole source lighting
versus producing a plug in a greenhouse
so what we did is is we maintained a 23
degree
constant day or night temperature and we
wanted to achieve a daily light integral
of about 10 and a half moles
so in the greenhouse we wanted to
achieve that with sunlight
plus supplemental lighting and in the
grow chamber we wanted to achieve that
just with sole source leds
so these are the different treatments
that we had in the greenhouse so we had
a no supplemental lighting control and
we decided we didn't obviously in the
two previous studies we didn't have
a ambient control and that was something
that
when i talked to growers i obviously
have an extension appointment
they often don't realize the benefits of
using supplemental light so i wanted to
really
you know show them that there are
differences
and then in terms of our supplemental
lighting treatments those lights were on
for 16 hours
we provided 70 micromoles and we had a
high pressure sodium lamp
we also use plasma lamps and then we had
one led treatment so we had one that had
88 percent red and 12 percent blue light
in the grow chambers we looked at two
light qualities so we had the same
as in the greenhouse and then we had
another treatment that had
18 percent more blue light
so these are various treatments so we
had our high pressure sodium
our greenhouse leds and then our plasma
in the greenhouse and then here are two
sole source lighting
treatments so we we did a multi-layer
production
here's our spectral distribution for the
various
light treatments
and this was probably uh in terms of the
studies that we did with
uh young plants you can definitely see
that there
are some major differences between the
plants that are produced in the
greenhouse so the ambient high pressure
sodium plasma
and then this supplemental leds you can
see the the differences between those
that were produced in the greenhouse
versus the ones that were produced under
sole source
leds so let's look at the data a little
closer
so those that were produced under plasma
lamps were quite elongated compared to
the other supplemental lighting
treatments as well as under sole source
lighting
we also found that the relative
chlorophyll content so we used basically
used a spad meter
and as you provided supplemental light
or
sole source light we definitely saw that
the relative
chlorophyll content increased but a big
increase under
sole source lighting in terms of leaf
area
leaf area increased when you provided
obviously more light
in terms of root dry mass as we would
expect uh compared to the ambient
control and the one thing i forgot to
mention
is the ambient
treatment we had about six and a half
moles of light and that was obviously
from the sun and then we were providing
an additional
four moles from from the supplemental
lighting so we saw an increase
in terms of our root dry mass but the
highest occurred under sole source
lighting and then we had an increase in
shoot dry mass but it was relatively
similar between the various lighting
treatments
so again we finished the crop under a
common environment to see if there were
any residual effects
and here is where we we did see some
differences
and one of the differences that you see
is obviously petunias are a long day
plant
so they require long days in order to
flower so under our ambient conditions
in the winter after three weeks they had
not flowered
plasma lamps provide quite a bit of heat
so that obviously helped in terms of
time to flower
the high pressure soda there is a flower
bud there it's hard to see
but here what we can see is that when we
had
only 12 blue light basically we were
providing about 22 micro moles of blue
light
there was a delay in terms of time to
flower not a significant delay
but work that's been done at michigan
state has actually shown that you can
use blue light
to um and basically use blue light
instead of far red light to induce
flowering responses in
in flora culture crops so we're actually
going to do some more work
in this area this coming winter
so in terms of of time to flower you
definitely see
that the uh that there were differences
hide it flower
in terms of horticulturally those
differences were not very
significant so we found in this study
that the quality of bedding plant
seedlings
produced under sole source excuse me
supplemental lighting was similar or
greater to those grown under ambient
light
also seedlings of the species that we
studied
were of higher quality or similar
quality when they were growing under
sole source lighting when we compared
those to supplemental
and the only two species where we found
that there was a difference in time to
flower was
impatience and the petunia that i showed
you today
so we believe that sole source lighting
is
is a viable option for growers who would
like to produce
bedding plant seedlings indoors because
they can obviously
control the parameters not only the
light but also temperature
humidity and carbon dioxide which is
going to produce
uniform cuttings or excuse me uniform
seedlings throughout
the peak production cycle
this is a study that we basically just
finished up a few weeks ago i actually
just got the
data from my student a few days ago
so josh well there's two josh's but josh
garavac
wanted to look at producing microgreens
indoors and he wanted to basically look
at both
light quantity as well as like quality
so we had three species that we looked
at
we used basically a fiber hydroponic
tray
it's a it's a pad and i'll show you a
little bit later and
our environmental set points
were 21 during the day 17 at night
and then we maintained a relative
humidity of 50
during the day and 60 at night and then
we had a set point of 500 parts per
million
co2 in terms of the leds that we used in
this study
we used the the same leds that we've
that i've showed you in the previous
study
but we had an led on this one that had
far red light
and then this one had a green light
and we achieved three target daily light
integrals so we basically wanted to have
a low
dli and then increase that amount
to from 6 to 12 and then 18
and these lamps were on for 16 hours a
day
so here's our various uh leds so you can
see
the uh what they look like and obviously
what
the micro greens look like under the
leds so you can see that when we have
the
the green and blue you can actually see
the
the
actual color of the micro greens
so here's our spectral distribution for
the
various uh treatments obviously as as
you increase that intensity
uh you see that the peaks also increase
it's a little bit it might be a little
bit difficult for you to to see this
from the back but what's the one
major difference that you notice when
you increase
the daily light integral
okay i hear bill bill basically said the
answer there
so this is something that we have
noticed um
when you increase the amount of blue
light we
we actually noticed this on geraniums so
you think of a zonal geranium and you
know
the zonal part when we increased that
amount of blue light
we saw an increase in anthocyanins here
we're basically
what in the 11 to 12 range
in terms of blue light but with an
increased daily light integral whether
you
had far red or green light you
definitely see
an increase in anthocyanins here's
another species this is a
kohlrabi a species that doesn't
necessarily show
the red pigmentation or anthocyanins
and here we're basically looking at
those micro greens so
you see that under a low daily light
integral it doesn't really matter in
terms of the light quantity
as you would expect they're much more
elongated but it really depends on the
market right some
individuals might want microgreens that
are a little bit taller
others may not with that increased daily
light integral we see that they're
much more compact and also we see that
expression of anthocyanins
so let's look at uh some of let's look
at the data so
obviously those were all done at one
temperature
yes yes exactly
so here we're looking at the hypocaudal
length so we've got our
are basically our three like uh
quantities and our increasing daily
light integral from 6 to 18 moles
so as we increase our daily light
integral the hypocotyl length decreases
on in terms of leaf area the more light
we provide them
the smaller the leaf area so is that a
good or a bad thing well in terms of
of microgreens what is it that we're
ultimately
trying to achieve right more biomass and
so that might not necessarily
be a good thing where we have a decrease
in
leaf area here we have a percent dry
weight
so obviously increasing
light quantity we have an increase in
dry weight
in terms of like quantity there are
really no differences
here we're looking at the relative
chlorophyll content so again
some slight increases with increased
daily light integral
but really this is i think one of the um
nice things is we looked at total
anthocyanins and you can definitely see
that with that increased
like quantity there's definitely a
difference
in the total anthocyanins and this is
for the kohlrabi we if we would have
looked at the other species that
definitely has a dark darker foliage we
probably would have seen more dramatic
of a difference we looked at total
phenolics there were virtually no
differences between
uh those light quantity different light
quantities and light qualities
so this leads us to another study
this is garrett owen and he's been
working in on this for
about a year now one of the things that
we typically tend to notice when we go
to production greenhouses especially
in march and april is you see a lot of
this
you know there's a lot of hanging
baskets and then obviously crops growing
below
well panacetium rubrum purple fountain
grass is a very popular
ornamental grass one of the problems
however
is that because growers have such well
especially in the north low light levels
and then you put hanging baskets above
them you're really reducing that
daily light integral and so often uh
these grasses are actually
green they're not very purple um you
know you take a closer look and this
is purple fountain grass but you
wouldn't know that if if you were just
looking at it in
in a garden center or in a greenhouse
so obviously color is a key component
consumers
obviously buy purple fountain grass
because it's purple they want to have
add some color into their landscape
as well as when we think of red leaf
lettuce so often when you go into a
greenhouse
and they're not providing supplemental
light their red leaf lettuce
is green and so in terms of color
obviously it's attributed to chlorophyll
carotenoids flavonoids
and anthocyanins this is a
purple fountain grass that's been cut
back it was grown in a greenhouse in the
glass glaze greenhouse during the summer
and you can obviously see the
the increased anthocyanins
so as i mentioned before with the
addition of blue light
we've noticed uh that you can uh
increase anthocyanin production and
obviously there has had been some work
that had
showed this previously so we thought of
of a new concept it was basically called
end of production supplemental lighting
so let's say a grower produces their
lettuce or their pennisetum under the
same conditions they always do
but they light the crop at the end so
let's say anywhere from
one to two weeks before they're going to
ship that crop out
they can increase the color enhance the
quality
so we thought of a way of
quantifying this by using a uh
a portable meter this is a meter that's
often used in the food industry
to measure color um
so what we did is is with the
pentacetum as we started off with plugs
that were grown in
new hampshire so you can definitely see
how light
in color they are not much purple
pigmentation we grew those out
to for about 55 days and in order to
create the daily light integral that we
would have during peak production
which would be march april
we had a daily light integral about 6
moles this is the
daily light integral that we would find
under those those hanging baskets
we then basically place the plants under
end of production lighting so i'm going
to show you the different treatments
our daily light integral basically from
the
sun was close to nine moles of light and
these are the various treatments so we
had
a control photo periodic control that's
which gave us about
four micro moles of light then we had
a treatment where we had 100 red a
combination of 50
50 red and blue i get our
88 12 and then we had uh 100
blue at 25 50 or 100 micromoles
so here's our our spectral quality for
the various treatments
and here we're looking at the um the
lettuce grown under the
50 50 red and blue leds 100 percent
excuse me yes 100 blue leds and here we
have the
the panacetum here's at night so you can
actually see uh
the leds and how the uh the lettuce
looks quite
dark but i'll show you what it actually
looked like so these are basically
using that colorometer we looked at the
l star
the a star and the b star and i'll talk
about that in just a bit
so basically the the al star is a
measure of lightness
so um as you get closer to zero
whatever that meter is measuring is more
on the
towards uh black then as the number
increases towards
100 it's more white in terms of what we
were looking for was more of this
red green so a positive a star told us
the the pigments were obviously more red
and in terms of b-star
whether there was a tendency of of the
pigments
turning more blue so we took
measurements
on day one basically when those plants
were placed under end of production
lighting
and then at 3 5 7 14 and 21 days
so this is what our plants look like so
this was about two weeks or three weeks
excuse me
uh before a grower would typically ship
out the plant toward
to a garden center or retail
greenhouse so these are initial
measurements
in terms of the l star a star and b star
and this is after seven days of
end of production lighting so here again
the all-star is a measure of lightness
from
white to black so our control you can
see
was about 31.1 and we saw
a decrease in that number when we had a
combination of both red and blue light
as well as one we provided a hundred
micromoles of blue light alone
if we light the crop for yet another
week
we see that obviously the plants are
obviously much darker in color and we
see a
again the decrease in that l star what
about the a star
well a negative means green
a positive means blue so as we go from
the control
to a 50 50 uh combination of red and
blue or
100 micro moles of blue we obviously see
that number is
is more positive and now visually we can
see that but we wanted to quantify that
and if we add another week we see that
that number definitely
increases so the longer we have those
plants under that end of production
red or blue or 100 blue we definitely
saw a difference
and then here we're looking at the b
star so this is a change from
yellow to blue so again um
control was 6.2 we see that that
number has decreased so we're becoming
more blue and again
as we increase the the time
so here's a visual close-up of this is
after 21 days of end of production
lighting and we're looking at individual
uh leaf blades so that 50 50 combination
or the 100 mic 100 micromoles of blue
we definitely see that those blades have
colored up and the really interesting
thing is
if you were to pick up let's say we had
two leaf blades that were
like this if you were to pick this one
up it would be green
underneath so it's it's really only
those uh leaves that are that are
receiving that
higher intensity of of uh blue light are
actually
uh the anthocyanins are increasing in
those leaves
so here's a close-up this is uh 14 weeks
later so you can definitely see the
difference
in terms of of the color
we also looked at a cultivar of geranium
this one has a really dark foliage it's
called black velvet and again you can
see that
a 100 micro moles of a blue light or a
combination
of this is just 100 percent red or
or combination of red and blue
definitely increases
the pigmentation we also wanted to look
at lettuce as i mentioned before
red leaf lettuce growers often have a
challenge under low light conditions of
of actually having it be so these are
all red leaf lettuce cultivars but you
would not
know that because they were obviously
grown under a low dli of 6 moles
so again we looked similar treatments
and again
here's the al star you can definitely
see after seven days
that number has decreased really with
the lettuce
five days was enough to get it to go
from basically green
to a nice dark red
here's our a star you definitely see
that number has
has increased quite a bit
as well as our b star
so with our pentacetum we found that
anywhere from 7 to 14 days of end of
production lighting
whether we provided a combination of red
or blue light or
100 percent blue light at 100 micro
moles was effective
at increasing the pigmentation change in
color
and with the um
red leaf lettuce five to seven days was
enough
again using the same uh two treatments
and the last study that i'm going to
talk about today is basically
looking at so obviously here we're
looking at the photoperiodic responses
so the greenhouse industry typically
uses
incandescent bulbs to induce flowering
so we can obviously classify a lot of
our greenhouse floor culture crops as
day neutral
uh short day as well as long day
in order to schedule these crops into
for specific market dates
we can use photo period
the typical things that growers will use
is either a night interruption so
they basically will turn on these lamps
from let's say
10 pm to 2 am to interrupt the night and
basically
the plants perceive a long day or they
can use day extension lighting
where at sunset they'll turn on the
lights for a specific amount of time
to provide a long day so uh you know
these are
our various treatments that growers can
use here we have a point poinsettia
crops so they're using
a blackout cloth to obviously provide a
short day to induce the crop
in the flower or here they're using day
extension
so as i said before incandescent bulbs
have been used for
for many years they emit a relatively
low
amount of red light and a high amount of
far red light
obviously far red light is what's needed
in order to induce
flowering they're very electrically
inefficient only about
six percent efficiency short life span
and obviously they're being phased out
of production so what is what are
growers going to use
well there's our next alternative is the
compact fluorescent lamp
the only problem with these lamps is
they emit a high amount of red light and
a relatively low
amount of far red light um
with certain species like wave petunias
which have a high response in terms of
their
or in terms of of light for a long day
response they flower
it's delayed basically under compact
fluorescent lamps
the life of cfls is also reduced by the
number of times that they're turned on
and off which can be a problem
and of course they contain mercury which
has some
serious disposal issues high pressure
sodium lamps can also be used for
photoperiodic lighting
you can use them for cyclical lighting
but of course they're energy intensive
they're expensive
and they emit heat so
we have leds uh with leds as
i've showed you we have different light
qualities that we can use
um they have a longer operating life the
spectra can be tailored
uh based on what whatever response we're
looking for whether it's
as i showed you before a
photomorphogenic response
or photoperiodic response the only
problem is the cost
so these are commercially available led
lamps that
are now on the market so what is the
incandescent bulb cost
for a four pack i think you could
probably get them for about two dollars
and
uh cfl not very much these are about
fifty dollars so
in terms of the the life you know they
they can last
many many years i believe the estimate
is about 50 000 hours
but of course you know growers in order
to get them to
to switch over to these that's a big
investment
so what we did is we looked at a wide
variety of both long day
and short day plants and we wanted to
um well i'm getting ahead of myself we
basically had an automatic
blackout curtain system so we
had a nine hour base photo period which
was from the sun
which was from 8 am to 4 pm
and then we provided high pressure
sodium or
increase the daily light integral with
high pressure sodium lamps which gave us
about 70 micromoles at plant height
we had a common greenhouse environment
for betting plant production
and the one thing that we wanted to look
at were the responses under low daily
light integral
versus high high daily light integral
we created so we used day extension so
we had a 10 hour photo period of 13 or
16 hours
where basically the lamps were on for
either one four
or seven hours and the first lamp
basically contained
red light white light and far red light
and this lamp only contained red and
white so no far red
the one thing that we had been hearing
from growers especially growers in the
south
or on the west coast was that they could
use
this red and white lamp and basically
they would have a flowering response
where growers in the north would say
that they could not use
these lamps only these so what's what's
the one thing in terms of using far red
light that
i've obviously told you the benefits in
terms of flowering but what's one of the
negative drawbacks of far red
stem elongation so that's that's a bad
word in
in the greenhouse industry um so here's
our our photo
periodic lighting we were providing um
we wanted to provide
two micro moles of photoperiodic light
because that's
what a grower would typically provide so
we actually had to use a screen over
these lamps because our system is
is quite low and you can see that we
we only place plants where they would
receive two micro moles and not near
or directly underneath those lamps so
here's our
our pansy crop you can see we achieved a
daily light integral of about six moles
here we have our leds that had red white
and far red light
so this is a long day plant so under a
10 hour photo period you see that it
took
61 days to flower when we provided
16 a 16 hour photo period we reduced
that by nearly three weeks
so if you're really you know if you're
trying to schedule this crop into flower
obviously providing long days
is going to reduce that time to flower
what about
under just red and white light well you
can see that there's basically no
statistical difference so
under a low daily light integral even
though we were providing
long days the crop was delayed by uh
quite a bit compared to when we use far
red light
so again the negative drawback of using
that far red light
is there was an increase in stem
elongation
when we compared those crops that were
grown under red white far red
versus just red and white light alone so
here's our pansy or excuse me petunia
crop
relatively low daily light integral
under six moles of light
you can see that as you increase your
photo period there's a
reduction in time to flower of course
there's that negative drawback in terms
of that stem elongation because of that
far red light
under just red and white light the crop
whether it was growing under a short day
or a long day flowered
basically at the same time again we see
the
the difference in height and there's
definitely differences between the two
leds
here's a snapdragon again a delay
under short days and a delay when we use
just red and white light
so this coming summer we're going to do
the work where we're going to look
at a higher daily light integral and see
if
our hypothesis is that growers in the
south
and in the west coast one of the reasons
they can use these
red and white leds is that they're
getting enough far red light because
they have such a high daily light
integral
versus in the north so again
those height differences and here what
we're looking at
is a shore day plant so marigolds are a
short day plant they're a facultative
short egg plant
you can see that when we grow them under
short days they flower faster
than under long days eventually
obviously they will flower under long
days
so here we have a daily light integral
of about 8 moles and here
15 moles you can see that there's
not a lot of difference in terms of the
short days but we are going to look
at this with long day plants this coming
summer when we can really achieve these
high daily light integrals
so some of the conclusions from this
study is that under low dll
low dli low intensity leds with far red
light obviously
they increase stem elongation but they
hasten flower
time to flower for long day plants
under low dli the leds that had
did not have far red light obviously
there was reduced stem elongation but
there was a delay in time to flower
so in terms of growers in the north they
can use
these leds in lieu of
let's say a compact fluorescent or an
incandescent and they can have market
ready
plants obviously it's very species
dependent in terms of the response
so with that i'd like to thank the
following
organizations companies for obviously
funding
as well as for plant material
fertilizers
etc and with that
i think we have some time for for some
questions
uh basically the question was are t5
uh lamps being used in greenhouses and
were you asking basically for the
photoperiodic lighting or
oh no just in any commercial capacity
because the only place i see them is for
um
is for like uh house plants and like
home gardening and stuff okay so think
of the fixture
and so in a greenhouse when we want to
provide whether it's supplemental
or photoperiodic lighting we want to get
as much sunlight as possible right
well with a fixture for like like a t5
that's a that's a lot of fixture where
you're basically blocking out a lot of
sunlight
and so that's that's one of the reasons
why we don't see them in greenhouses but
we do see them in the same road chambers
or for
indoor production of sure house plants
um the led fixtures you showed in the
last experiment looked like
they were edison base designed for 120
volt
fixtures and
if we move to a future where we get away
from the backward compatibility
you can make them more affordable
because there you have
your uh your power regulation circuitry
you need one
per bulb and it's
um
if you just forget about the backward
compatibility
you can you can then design
your leds to be optimal uh
for cost and other properties as well
yeah so so the um leds that i showed in
the last experiment
they're basically a replacement for
incandescent or compact fluorescent
where they're a screw-in tight bulb
where all of the others
look low intensity so um yeah they're
basically made to replace those lamps
where
the other lamps that i showed you right
now
there are some lamps on the market in
terms of the supplemental lighting that
are
uh called a high pressure sodium
replacement
but uh they're still i would say a few
years where we're really
it's going to take a while while longer
to get those
hps replacements with a high intensity
led
have you done any work with analyzing
the cost
of the you know the purchase cost of the
leds versus
hps or fluorescence in the case of
chamber lighting okay so the question
was have we done
any uh cost comparison in terms of using
high pressure sodium versus the leds and
so we were part of the usda
ser scr our grant and there's someone at
purdue who's actually doing that
component so hopefully within this year
you will have all of that
it's taken a lot longer it's much more
difficult than we first
anticipated in terms of getting the the
data
because he's basically getting the data
from all of the researchers to then look
at
the cost and you know how long does a
grower have to have
the leds and so on
in your last study it seemed like stem
elongation and
flowering response in long day plants
were closely coupled
and i wonder if there's any way to break
that
that connection perhaps by cyclic
lighting of some sort so that you're
giving
as you remember that at least the theory
says that
if the last light the plant sees in a
day
then if it's red then the stems will
stay short
if it's far red then the stems will
become longer
but i don't know if that also influences
the for the period response as far as
flowering's concerned
so the question was uh in in our studies
we use day extension lighting
and uh what what sort of responses would
we give with night interruption lighting
and so eric uncle at michigan state he
is focusing on the
night interruption and typically a night
interruption
is four hours you can do cyclical
lighting which
obviously you can reduce the amount of
time that you lightly crop
and he's actually yes found that a four
hour night interruption of the birds are
much more compact than under day
extension
as you would expect
with the the phillips i think the term
you use is like production
module so so phillips i guess has come
up with some
recipes of red and blue leds that they
think work pretty well are those
generally
useful for a wide variety of plants or i
need to
to what extent will there need to be
optimization for different crops
so from the first studies that we did we
had the 100
red the 85 15 and then the 70 30.
um across the various vending plant
species we found that
85 15 was a good combination you know
when you took
everything into account and the work
that they had done in the netherlands
they came out with the ada 12 which i
showed a lot of the
questions and so that was a good um
should i say uh basically a good
combination of both red
and blue light that they found with uh
they were looking primarily in
vegetables
in the netherlands and uh
so that's a good good combination
obviously the more blue light you add
the more expensive
pictures what's the psychological effect
of these weird colors
that's a very good question so i can get
back
uh well this is low intensity so it
really
doesn't work but where that when we are
in the growth chamber
this has been shown at various places
when you're under leds some people
actually get nauseous
i am one of them
so
for example this is in the walk-in
chamber
when you walk into the chamber and let's
say you're in there for even a minute
you walk out and everything you see is
great if i'm in there for more than
15 minutes i feel nauseous when i come
out and there's a lot of people that say
the same
thing so that that is definitely a
problem
you can't really see it
these are more of a red and white and
those don't really bother
uh your eyes nearly as much as when you
have the blue light
alone or excuse me red and blue light so
the addition of the green light
or phosphorus coating on the leds
definitely helps out a lot
so we are going to be doing more studies
with
white light and i think for humans
that's definitely going to
be a better
thinking in terms of those of us that
get nauseous under them
maybe instead of recruiting in grad
school you should go to the dance clubs
you talked a little bit earlier about
how much more
flexibility you have in the geometry of
the layout
so that it doesn't block light that sort
of thing um
what kinds of things might we expect in
terms of the geometry of where the
lights are placed so you get the right
light distribution and they're not in
the way for other things you're trying
to do
so that is one thing with the uh
high pressure sodium versus an led so a
high pressure sodium we tend to have
more of the light
you know spreads out with for leds it's
very directional
so a lot of the leds that are on the
market you have to have them
relatively close to the crops in order
to get a uniform light intensity
some of the newer higher intensity ones
that are
quoted as the hbs replacement
they're getting better because they're
concentrating more leds
and let's say an area this big
and so you're getting you can place them
higher
and you're getting that increased
uniformity but
one thing that i tell growers when they
ask me about supplemental life is they
say wait
they're really interested in the
technology um but
i i tell them if i were you i would wait
and if there's if they still want to
go into the leds i tell them to look at
the various
there's so many leds on the market
there's a lot of claims
that are sometimes a little outrageous
so
just tell them to do studies on their
own and see which one
best fits their particular situation
you can get the white leds and holes
embedded in this
uh clear silicone like stuff they're not
very expensive they're pretty bright
very flexible literally but also in
terms of installation
is that one of the hardware
implementations you think we might see
for supplemental lighting
well the thing you need to think about
with leds is that the life
of the led is dependent on the
temperature
and so uh in a greenhouse you know
especially where we're going to mount
these
um it's definitely going to have an
effect on
how long those leds are going to last
and so the method of cooling
is very important so with a system like
that
um yeah i mean they can be relatively
cheap but you're probably going to have
to replace them quite a bit
and i'm not sure what sort of uh you
know intensity you would actually
um
yes yes so the first leds that i showed
um
we had basically a band on them to pull
them
and in some instances those leds use
more energy than the high pressure
sodium so
it's the method of cooling definitely
affects
the energy usage
all right let's thank our speakers
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu